[Música]
[Aplausos]
[Risadas]
[Música]
o andré eu pensava sobre os meus mundos
eu ouvi uma música chamada hoje
de um tubo isto é nenhum renan daniel
traz em sua música uma grande mistura de
folclore jazz
os cara de clássico
o mais interessante é que o molde é uma
cidade na noruega
ela acontece o festival de jazz
um dos que mais recebe destaque naquela
região
[Música]
eu fico imaginando 9 e e consigo
visualizar muitas coisas onde
provavelmente é um lugar com muita alma
imagina
[Música]
pensamentos à parte com 12 anos eu
vivenciei a minha primeira experiência
significativa com a música
por coincidência foi o meu primeiro
contato um com a solidão
foi nesse momento que eu tomei
consciência da minha música
passei anos sem entender esse episódio
sem entender a ligação entre a música e
estar só
[Música]
e perceber que são nesses momentos
profundos que descobrimos e tomamos
consciência da nossa alma
e foram nessas ocasiões e eu senti que
alguns que elevaria a muitos lugares
como esse me faria sentir muitas coisas
como estou sentindo agora
[Música]
eu vivo para tocar a minha música
este é o sentido da minha vida quando eu
decidi cortar cabelo eu não imaginava
que seria dessa forma
porém foi algo muito natural
a música já estava em mim eu
simplesmente botei para fora
muito do que eu já sentia na verdade o
mais difícil mesmo foi aprender cortar
cabelo e fazer a barba
poderia ser um farmacêutico cozinheiros
em la
eu precisava fazer algo com a minha vida
e eu queria fazer com minhas próprias
mãos
eu queria ter interferência de ninguém
ter que ser eu
somente eu
[Música]
a música me ajuda a expressar que lançou
a música me apoia o apoio da música com
ela o consigo expressar o que faço uma
forma verdadeira e autêntica
e tudo isso ficou mais claro e consegui
entender essas coisas mais ainda quando
eu conheci o jazz som da liberdade de
improviso
[Música]
i
eu vivo de sc som já existe
todos os dias eu vivo momentos de
espontaneidade e liberdade e no jazz
você não têm como rolar essa
possibilidade não existe
onde é que você tem alguns minutos para
falar o que realmente está sentindo
[Música]
você nunca vai conseguir reproduzir o
mesmo som porque o espontâneo é algo que
você queria no momento
gesi é um som da surpresa
você estuda durante anos e quando vai
tocar preciso esquecer tudo o que
estudou só assim você consegue ser livre
pra expressar realmente está sentindo
e é por isso que o sesi está na minha
vida para ouvir
primeiro você precisa sentir dessa forma
você vai realmente visualizar o seu
mundo
[Música]
mas o que cabelo e barba tem a ver com a
música para mim tudo
a música está conectada com tudo o que
você faz é musical comer andar dormir e
respirar mas somos seres musicais
eu tomei consciência da minha música
tudo ficou mais claro mais fácil
conectar cada cliente é uma nova música
um novo ângulo uma nova projeção ou
selecionando dividindo cortando
pincel em movimentos criando uma espuma
a lâmina na pele gerando um certo atrito
com a longa gravado ano ou até mesmo
combinando e misturando formas
geométricas criando um certo caos mendes
tesouro e movimentos constantes criando
um ritmo bom som ou identificando os
elementos naturais e espontâneos na
personalidade e do estilo de cada
cliente e senta na cadeira e vivendo e
vivenciando novas experiências
o mesmo vai passando por transformações
e novos elementos vão sujeito que o
silêncio vai pairando e as palavras não
são mais necessárias
[Música]
e aí está a minha música vai
improvisando sem perder a referência que
meu cliente fazendo victor e qualquer
forma pré-estabelecida buscando sempre
os caimentos naturais e espontâneos do
cabelo ou da barba
a música o corte
simplesmente acontece
vou criando a minha arte é a minha
música em cada cliente é claro com o
tempo foi evoluindo foi tornando tudo
isso mais visível as pessoas começaram a
perceber a sentir mas foi fazer sempre
de uma forma livre e espontâneo é que as
pessoas começaram a a visualizar a
enxergar o meu mundo e este é o meu
mundo
minha visão de mundo
o mundo que eu criei para viver para
expressar que eu sou compartilhar o que
se lê
uma bateria de uma cadeira só lugar para
compartilhar viver experiências com
outros artistas para sentir a música
[Música]
criando o som da surpresa aprendendo a
desaprender
[Música]
dessa forma a cortar cabelo fazer barba
simplesmente é um meio de transportar a
minha música
isso é feito por nós
os músicos que transformam a minha
cadeira em uma nova música
[Música]
a cada nova hora a cada novo dia
a cada novo encontro
eu sou músico que não usa instrumentos
convencionais
qual o seu instrumento
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]